I don't want you to date me just because
you find it Asians attractive but also
don't tell me that you don't date Asian
that's not going to do anything for this
interaction
I don't really identify or ascribe so
just one specific gender presentation my
gender is kind of like an ongoing
project and an ongoing dialogue my
pronouns are she and her
I don't switch I'm never anything
different on specific days whenever I'm
in new spaces and people ask me you know
what are my pronouns I say they them he
him she her I you literally cannot
misgender me my pronoun is they them I
don't want to be lumped into male or
female and growing up for me I always
identified as almost like neither I came
out I think it was my senior year of
high school I told everybody at the
dinner table I could just imagine my
parents being like okay Jensen I'm like
if it was getting cold but they're kind
of just like yeah sounds about right
they were just like you know we're gonna
love you regardless I saw the movie blue
is the warmest color she does you keep
in touch down on the floor Thank You
Ruth
I'm after much more food to work just
rugby and I was like hey message
received and I wrote this essay like
immediately afterwards I played the
trailer for the movie to my family and
then I made them all read the essay with
me while I just sat there I thought it
was a really fine I was so like yeah
this is gonna be what it is coming out
and doing this thing and then just
bowled I hit public school in tenth
grade when I was like maybe I'm a little
gay but I'm not sure I was like mom I
don't think I'm straight she's like oh
no it's just the face we never talked
about it again so I came out in high
school first to my friends and my peers
I remember one of my teachers who was
actually my math teacher and he was
Asian
he was like Sam no you're not gay and
and God loves you I didn't know how to
challenge him other than and just exist
and it was a hard time for me because I
was going through like almost took my
life
and I think especially being queer in
Asian and having to like uphold not only
the standards of like being what it
meant to be Asian but also always having
to choose which identity I want to fight
for when I'm seeking out community in
asian-american spaces I'm too queer or
I'm too non-binary it's really hard to
find these spaces that sort of coalesce
all my different identities together I
rely on what I've learned as an
asian-american to foster community as a
queer person the sort of perception that
I give off most of the time when I am
meeting new people is that of somebody
who is an Asian man and so that already
has like so much things to unpack within
itself like Western concepts of
masculinity this inherent femininity
that Asian people possess I as a queer
non-binary chinese-american family just
don't date white people anymore
I need someone to be eye level with me
about so many different issues and
unfortunately I think when it comes to
like
romance we have this very colonized
notion of like what a beautiful and
incredible and like worthy of love
partner is and what I've realized is
like assist slim Eurocentric a beautiful
white person is like not the like thesis
of beauty and it's not like the ultimate
version of like what we should aspire to
or aspire to want that's a big thing for
me because that means that I love myself
better
my first date mates was not Asian but
after a few months I realized they had
an asian fetish I don't want you to date
me just because you find Asians
attractive but also don't tell me that
you don't date Asians that's not going
to do anything for this interaction that
and also don't date me as a non-binary
person to like prove your locus or look
improve how like the rest of you are
about gender it sucks when you learn it
too late like you got to go back and be
like this X looks like me this X looks
like constants woo this X looks like
drama Chan and you're like wait a minute
you love crazy being queer and Asian is
really difficult and hard because there
aren't very many representations of
queer agents out there growing up I felt
like I was always looking for folks to
look up to I feel like with this sort of
Asian wave that people are calling it
with you know fees are which Asians
fresh-off-the-boat
tell the boys I love it before I think
we are just beginning to get a scope of
what it means to be somebody of the
Asian Diaspora I need darker skinned
Asians we need South Asians we need
disabled Asians working-class Asians
because we are infinitely complex so we
need all that representation
[Music]